hey I just picked up a background
chatter from the printer right so before
I get to talking about this literary
masterwork I should probably mention
that if you didn't see it I went to
Vienna to present my work along with Tom
my colleague who sits over there we gave
all presentations on our research and
unexpectedly also presented our
supervisors work at a poster session and
then I was on a bunch of panels about
social media in filmmaking
that's all in one vlog I resisted the
urge to make it like five videos along
in a series because let's face it my
life's not that interesting and since I
came back I've basically been
exclusively working on this I say that
actually in the aftermath of the
conference I had several days where I
just had to do absolutely nothing
because I was I put in so much work it
was it was like there's this increasing
function of work that went into my PhD
and then I presented it and then I just
crashed for a bit because I was just
totally burned out hopefully other PhD
student about this before and it's not
just me but I just had to take time off
my sanity but since then I've been
writing this background chapter so
theses are typically five six seven
chapters long and they're normally
between 150 and 250 pages ish se which
means that given all the other guff that
you have like your bibliography list of
figures glossary titles stuff all the
stuff that you kind of have to put in
because of university each chapters
normally about 25 to 30 pages long so
the pretty meaty works and this is my
that's gonna be out of focus isn't it
all done silent this is my background
chapter so this is the second chapter in
the thesis even though it says one I
haven't rendered the whole thing yet
this is basically the first chapter is
at least in my case it does vary from
person to person you kind of introduce
your problem you're saying this is what
research topic I'm looking at the second
top the second chapter is much longer
and it goes through all the background
and because you're effectively
summarizing in my case the earliest
reference I have is 1881
some effectively summarizing you know
130 years of science in some cases
trying to represent arguments for and
against different points without losing
any accuracy doing that in an engaging
way that isn't just dry and boring it's
really hard so this has taken me the
best part of a month to write it's
actually technically not the first time
I tried to write it at the start the PhD
here at Exeter we're asked to do a
literature review which is meant to
really form the basis of your background
chapter of your thesis so it's like in
the bank it's done from an early point
but I ignored that completely in style
again because the direction of my thesis
has changed slightly so this was kind of
from scratch and it's a pretty meaty one
this is it's just shy of 25 pages at the
moment there's still one or two figures
missing and there's one section I
haven't quite finished yet I'll get to
that in a second so it's um it's doing
pretty good it's for a first draft I'm
pretty happy with it I haven't changed
my supervisors because I don't want that
much red ink on it just yet but yeah
there's one section here where I haven't
actually bothered to convert a bunch of
terms in this equation so it's just
heating over stability need to look up
what that should be and like I said
there's a section at the end where I
have bits that just say don't understand
this to be honest and don't talk about
this where I need to finish it off but
I'm not going to finish it now because I
am sick to the back teeth of this bloody
thing because it's so dense and hard to
write I mean forget to say if there's
close to a hundred references in this
already and there's going to be more so
we're going to touch 150 references in
the whole thesis it's it's a really hard
thing to write and doing it allow me to
really think about what I'm doing in the
rest of my thesis so it's allowed me to
think about what I'm what variables like
PV mean what the plan is what I'm doing
and it's allowed me to form I had a
really crystal clear plan of what I'm
going to do which I then couldn't do
because I was busy writing the bloody
thing so I had a meeting with my
supervisors yesterday where I just said
you know what guys this is as good as
you're getting for the time being screw
this I'm going to do some real science
now to which they kind of went yeah it's
fair that standard board so I can ignore
this and get back to real work so with
that in mind in this video what I wanted
to talk about was
the main variable really that I'm
working with my thesis and is used a lot
in stratosphere and atmospheric sciences
generally which is called potential
vorticity or PV for short
now the last PhD watch video I talked
about PV inversion and I think I went a
little bit in the deep end I didn't go
give you guys a primer about what the
variable actually means to recap from
last time I basically said the PV
inversion is like if you know the
position of the football on a football
field and maybe a few other bits of
information you can work out what the
position of the players are that's a
process that's like PV inversion where
the position the ball is your PV
distribution where the PV is and the
atmosphere and the players positions are
the wind but what does PV itself
actually mean that's let's go to the
class science whiteboard that's the one
between your PhD put a little whiteboard
I think I'm over than pushing it a bit
hard this week I found a whiteboard this
room is actually really cool by the way
this is in the university building I'm
in this entire room is paneled with
whiteboards so you can write on any
surface you might get in trouble for
icing on some of them because some of
them are whiteboards but all the walls
are white boards so the usefulness of PV
comes from an idea called balanced flow
and this is the idea that in the
atmosphere the flow by that I mean the
velocities flow generally refers to
fluid moving so kippie ocean currents
that could be wind in the atmosphere in
the atmosphere we have what's called a
balanced flow which means that the flow
the velocity the wind speed is uniquely
determined by the distribution of mass
in the atmosphere now that nice a little
bit removed but the idea is that by
having by knowing any instant what the
where the masses which effectively means
where the pressure is you know what the
pressure is throughout it's not just at
the surface but throughout the
atmosphere there is only one set of
velocities that will come from that
configuration that's the idea of a
balanced flow that at any instant all
you need to calculate the velocities at
that instant is the mass distribution at
that time now the way that you get the
velocities from your pressure
distribution because we're
we relate the mass and the pressure by
what's called a hydrostatic relation
which organism hem that's teaspoon which
looks like this and by the way I'm still
working on how to get my font size
consistent in order to get from your
pressure your mass distribution to your
velocities you use what's called a
balanced relation now there are
different balance relations that work to
different levels of accuracy so the
simplest balance relation are the
geostrophic balance relations so this
basically gives you a derivative so it
gives you the velocity from a derivative
of your pressure field give some
constant in front this is the Coriolis
parameter and the density of the field
now this works pretty well a large-scale
system but it's not accurate enough for
doing well high accuracy stuff and also
like you enough for doing small scale
stuff so what we end up doing if you
want to be truly accurate is calculating
a quantity known as pv which acts as an
intermediary and has in specialized case
has a bounce relation associated with it
so the idea behind pv is let's say we
haven't observed all my own frames I
have all done so observe velocity
distribution v and we use that calculate
quantity which I'm gonna go Q big Q so
big it's just land frame which is the
potential vorticity now the formula for
Q I will talk about the second but this
encodes more information than V so yes
you need me to calculate it but let's
say we already knew it all right what Q
is then in that case we can actually
perform what's called a PV inversion
which is what I talked about last time
and get a velocity field from it but
more than that we can you do that
aversion and calculate the pressure the
temperature and the density fields so by
knowing what your PV is it's which it
literally is calculated from this but if
you know what's PV is and in particular
if you're forecasting with it which I'll
talk about in a second it's an
incredibly useful quantity it's got this
stuff bound up in it
is just a question of accessing it so
what does this actually look like so
this kind of scary-looking formula
behind me explains what cue potential
assisity is we're going to work through
this left to right I'm going splain
everything don't worry if you then get
math you are going to understand this
kind of promise so what this is telling
us is cue our potential vorticity is
proportional to this thing C gamma nor
that proportional means that it's equal
to this thing times a certain number
that stays the same for any value of
this so that could be tithe pi minus 1
whatever equal to with a constant okay C
gamma ignore this ignore ignore the now
behind a garden C gamma is the
circulation around the COEs contour
gamma so what does that mean right a
consult gamma is any contour and a
contour is just a close leap that's be
very careful that actually closed this
is an example curve which we call gap
but it could have been that or it could
have been
ah that so that's what the contact
that's what gamma means it's just a note
it's just a name the circulation is a
little difficult to explain and imagine
that you have a pipe right and you fill
it with water and you put a pump in it
so you've got water moving around your
pipe which is closed it's going to close
Lee then your circulation depends on the
speed of waters being pumped around it
and the length of the pipe now a no-no
cannot be positive or negative because
the border could be pumped in the same
direction that you defines be positive
like if you're looking for the top down
clockwise or counterclockwise or it
could be negative depending on your
definition right this can be positive or
negative now the true circulation is if
you take that pipe but it's a
hypothetical pipe that has the velocity
of the fluid in it let's say you
submerge it in a chanela it's not put in
the oceans but in the atmosphere and the
velocity of the effective Lassa T of
what would have been the water in the
pipe stick with me is the velocity of
the air at the place we put it in the
atmosphere so if I had like a loop here
this is a still room so the circulation
would be zero because it'd be it would
be the equivalent of the water standing
still but I'll put it up in the
atmosphere there's gonna be a wind
blowing across it and if there's like a
shear to it if it's blowing more across
one side the nodes across the other side
then the contribution from the side
where the wind is stronger is going to
be bigger than the contribution in the
other than in the other direction
because the leaves come back around of
the other side and that's the
circulation which we mathematically
write as the closed integral so the
integral is when you sum over all the
length of the pipe as all those grill is
a closed integral is just the fact that
is a closed pipe we have a velocity
times the elements of the pipe is and
screenfood the lens's in the way of the
screen really professional filmmaking
and the DX is the length of pipe that
you're considering at the particular
point where you're looking so the
velocities here while the velocity is
here and what the length of the pipe is
here a little bit understand I don't
worry the point is it's it's the
effective flow around
your loop most cases though you have
like a really small loop which is what
we tend to do in maps we tend to find
these things that can be arbitrary make
them infinitesimally small and at that
point you can most like your most like
you have just a flow that goes one
direction which means the circulation
will be zero because it's an equal
contribution along one side and then the
same contribution within the opposite
direction because your leapt back around
and they're going to be zero but if
there's a shear to it like if one side
stronger than the other or if there's
even a reversal you can get a large
circulation that can be positive or
negative so this is just the number
which means that this is just a number
as well it's just it's just like any old
number it will be positive because of
the young constant report
proportionality that we choose so it
would be minus 1 it might be 5 or PI or
million and one I was trying to think of
something but I remember wonders the
last column so this is a number which
means this is just a number so why is
this all useful now there's a property
which I haven't told you about this
which makes it useful hopefully this
will suddenly become clear but I'm
explaining it so probably wait thanks to
a Victorian physics formula but rather a
law called the Kelvin circulation
theorem which states that the
circulation around a loop in a fluid
where you will hour the loop to be moved
by the flow so if I put it up in the
atmosphere I allow that loop to be blown
along by the wind and it can be
distorted so if the if like if the wind
is going this way and then on the other
side of it was going this way it can be
stretched and pull apart but if you
allow yourself to do that if you allow
your lead to be moved by the fluid
that's in motion the circulation remains
constant and that's a very powerful
result for PV it's so so useful might
not be immediately clear why though so
let's say that we work out what Q is so
we you know an are bound like the thing
we're interested in so this is our
atmosphere the square of the whiteboard
is our atmosphere at every point we
calculate given that there's some flow
that's going on so there's a flow doing
yes across the whole thing right the
wind is blowing in that direction that
isn't actually there this is a
theoretical quantity the wind's blowing
across in this direction saying and
let's just say for the sake of argument
that we work out at every point that our
potential vorticity that circulation is
described by this so let's say zero in
loads of places but here it's large
let's say there was something
interesting going on with the wind I
didn't draw the wind correctly
okay now the circulation theorem tells
us that if we blow our PV of 10 support
is your the circulation along with the
flow
we know how that's described right if
the flow could do this were actually
raising it like let's you need to redraw
it sorry if we let the flow below see
this little bit of PV festered let's
just ignore the rest of it say that bit
of PV is smudged that way by the wind we
know how that smudging takes place
because we know what our wind field is
how because we know what our key field
is we know at any given instant if we
know what Q is we know what the wind is
doing then we know how the the the Q
distribution this blob is going to be
squished and smear and all that kind of
stuff we can calculate how much is going
to be distorted right in a reversible
way so we let's say we know what the
windows of start at time equals 0 plain
midnight we know what the wind is doing
then we want to know what the PV
distributions can look like at 1 o'clock
then we take the wind's at midnight and
we let it blow across this distribution
for an hour and at the other hour the PV
distribution out looks like this it's
been smeared why is that useful well
remember at the start from your PV you
can establish what P is where your
pressure is your density of the field
your temperature and your velocity so
effectively what we've done is taking
all these variables what really is just
the velocity is kind of Walden bundle
them all up into one quantity but then
it's easy to keep track of how it's just
it's distorted in a way that we can
predict by the circulation theorem by
the material conservation of it and then
in the future we we then have a new
potential vorticity distribution that we
have calculated and from that we can
predict what the velocity temperature
pressure density fields are going to be
in the future so it's like taking all
the information you have about the
atmosphere this whole state the
atmosphere scratching it up into a ball
and then you know how that ball is going
to move you know how it's going to be
distorted over time then you unpack all
of it and then you find out what the
atmosphere will be doing in the future
given how long you allowed that your
scrunched up ball to move around and be
distorted that's why PV is so useful
because we're lazy meteorologists and
physicists in the atmosphere we want to
keep track of loads of stuff at once but
we only want to have to keep track of
one variable and we know how this
variable changes over time in a very
predictable way
that's why PV is useful I had a mess I'm
really sorry if this section confused
you by the way it's quite advanced stuff
this was in my fourth year Oxford and I
tried to kind of simplify this if you if
you actually understood this please
comment because it'll be nice to know
that I didn't just waste your time and
if you didn't understand it please do
ask and I'll try and clarify anything
I'll include a reference by the way in
the description if you want to know more
about this from a mathematical
perspective I include a paper in
description but for now back to you in
the studio
me thanks
me if you enjoyed that which I hope you
did and he found it illuminating I like
to do this kind of videos a bit more in
the future where I do what my dad calls
chalk and talk
even though blessum chalk hasn't used
for a while actually no that's a lie my
undergrad lectures were in chalk so you
were right again that but yeah I'd like
to do more of these kind of videos and
maybe in a like a special video which
I'd link somewhere else I might go
through the proper derivation of the
quasi gist traffic potential vorticity
equation because I realized that most
people watching this don't want to see
that but if there's enough demand in the
comments then I will do it so if you
have any questions about PV please feel
free to put them down the comments I'll
try and answer there bear in mind I am
NOT an expert exactly on it and if you
also be HD student who are watching
these and you haven't introduced
yourself already there were loads in the
comments last time by the way it was
really so interesting to hear like the
kind of elevator pitch of what your
research is I love it so if you're a PhD
student watching this or master student
you know we don't discriminate um please
say introduces over the comments and say
what your research is about and also if
you have any suggestions about what
you'd like me to do in these videos in
the future I have an idea for next time
already I've got a few ideas but I'm
always open to being told what you guys
want to know about because ultimately
it's difficult to know what to cover
when you were the one from the inside
looking out really from your perspective
I want to know what you guys would find
interesting to know about the next time
I've got an idea which I'm going to try
and run with and it might involve me
wearing Hawaiian shorts we'll see I hope
you found this entertaining and if you
enjoyed it please do liked it feel free
to subscribe the channel for this and
more vlogs and book clubs and all kinds
of videos I'll even know what I'm doing
with this channel at the moment because
frankly that this PhD is eating my life
but I hope you enjoyed this thank you
for watching I'll see you next time